I have a bunch of questions but let's
start with we're gonna look back on
Jurassic world for a quick second if you
guys don't mind when you look back on
the film is there anything that you wish
you could like have one more day in post
and like tweak or is it sort of like I
did the best I could with the time I had
no I mean definitely I haven't seen it
in its entirety since it came out so I
saw the ending there I mean I think like
the obvious answer is like I would we
would I would just say no do not run in
the high heels like for sure 100% as far
as like the you know the rest of the
movie yeah like as time goes by you know
you evolve as a filmmaker and you know
you're the the way you you would want to
pace things changes and so I don't think
it would be even fair to let someone go
back in time and direct a movie that
they directed once you just you get it
and you have to set it aside and walk
away what were some of the really
difficult shots at the time that are now
way easier I don't know if they're
easier like that last shot that follows
everyone all the way down the street and
through the gift shop and back out
that's one long shot that started on a
dolly that then handed off to a guy on a
motorcycle that then handed off to a
techno crane and we knitted them all
together it's a minute long and it was
the biggest render that ILM had ever
done and it would take you know days to
like actually get to look at it so by
the time we finished the render we
didn't even have enough time to rerender
it we would have to just like paint any
fixes into it but it was extremely was a
heavy heavy shot are there any easter
eggs that have still not been found I
don't I mean maybe if someone spots one
I'll say yeah that was intentional but
okay what was the last thing that you
took out of the film before you picture
locked there was one little scene we
actually when we were at Skywalker doing
the sound we always show the movie to
everyone who works at Skywalker one week
ahead where we have to where we do have
time to change something there's a
little moment that's in the deleted
scenes which is just Jake Johnson Lauren
lapkus who are seeing the indominus you
know disappear and reappear on the
security camera and it was just this
little thing but we just felt like for
pacing we would take it out cuz we were
we were feeling the way the audience was
reacting in the theater
having that advantage of just being able
to like sense the just the EKG of the
movie just like its heartbeat as it goes
along it allowed us to to make little
changes the very last second I really
enjoyed fallen Kingdom this is gonna be
a fallen Kingdom question I really
enjoyed that film
my only grievance with the film is I
felt that the dinosaur price is that the
auction were a little low Oh
all the true story so Steven Spielberg
my boss felt that the dinosaur prices
were really high and so we got a note
like this is you know they're they're
too expensive bring them lower and we
felt you know I think to someone who's a
dinosaur fan dinosaurs could not be
priced high enough they're absolutely
priceless and so I think there was
something going on between like the
person who brought us all of this magic
has one opinion of the value of
dinosaurs and may not necessarily
recognize that to us the fans the
dinosaurs are are priceless that there
is no number that you could put on them
so there was just a difference of
opinion based on our experience with
Jurassic Park itself sure okay that's my
that's my grievance let's jump into I'll
tell him right now that that's literally
that's my one thing jumping into the
short talk a little bit about how this
whole thing came together and was there
anything let's actually start with that
how did this whole thing come together
this began Universal was asked you know
we be interested in doing a short and I
immediately just said yes and ran out of
the room don't change your mind I can't
believe you're letting us do this and so
a script came together really quickly
and Emily and I were already working
together on Jurassic world 3 and so we
know we collaborated to try and find a
way to tell really like you know the the
the story that you tell over the course
of a whole movie of you know beginning
with Wonder and heading into the people
feeling unsafe and then to being a
normal survival level danger and you
know elements family and all the things
we pack into it could we do that in
eight minutes and have it have a real
beginning middle and an end and escalate
to the level of insanity that these
movies tend to go to and and and and
that was really the attempt it for me it
was it was an opportunity to go back to
the absolute core of what I loved about
Jurassic Park
about the franchise in general you know
these the movies that we make therefore
a massive global audience and there's so
many different people in the audience
that have different needs from it then
you need to please everybody people love
like really really fast chases and
others like things that are slow and
suspenseful like this and so this was
just one chance for me to do just just
here is just my dissertation on what I
love about this franchise you know in in
a single short so I'm curious you guys
are you're busy writing the next feature
you get offered this thing how quickly
did you actually write this and then end
up shooting it I would say there's a
high degree of sort of professionalism
we were already deep in the groove on
three this you know colin has at this
point made so for so - it was it was
great to be there and I don't think it
didn't it didn't feel like we were
strained or didn't feel like anyone was
breaking his what no I I mean I guess
internally we were but we didn't let
anyone see it no never
we did it in five days in Ireland and
you know in in that period of time you
know we had to be extremely meticulous
and very very well-planned there was not
really much improv on the set we didn't
have the room for that and it's it's
actually surprised you'd think that just
a couple people in a box would be the
simplest thing to do and it was actually
more complex and difficult to execute
than a lot of the larger scenes that you
see in a movie like Jurassic world we
had a baby who at a certain point was
hanging upside down and we needed to be
careful you know just we wanted to make
sure this baby was safe and four moments
was was deeply unhappy but just four
moments and so we just had to know like
alright we've got it but every cry from
him is real he was not comfortable there
were two of them so there were twins and
so neither one was ever comfortable and
it was just cry I mean you know it was
bright it was perfectly safe normal it's
a normal thing yes I wanted to alter the
headline tomorrow is not going to be
pleasant
no perfectly safe but I am curious in
the writing process for putting this
thing together was there was
did you always zero in on this storyline
were you like brainstorming all these
other ideas and then you know what I
mean straight line straight line from
like conception to execution it to me it
felt like the most organic next step in
the process of these animals we're all
let out into the forest the first people
are going to run into er people who are
camping and so let's find a way to have
a you know a real family people to who
we care about who we can understand
right away who are dealing with
something that you know we many of us
have dealt with and you know a new
family that's coming together and you
know put them through this trial
together and I just got excited about
being able to strip it down and and not
have to you know deal with all of the
other elements of like oh it's a city
air cops are coming or the you know the
army or anything it's just human beings
and animals in nature and that how did
you actually keep this under wraps
because you also you have to cast and
you can't really tell people what you're
casting and there's so many parts of
this puzzle that could easily have
gotten out at some point
stay secret well I everyone at Jurassic
outpost who's here knows I know you guys
had it figured out I just want you to
there's there we have a great fan site
and they know everything and they knew
about this too but they were really cool
about it so thank you but no in general
you know we were in Ireland it was
January we went to you know Abbey Road
and you happen to be in London and and
got to see that which was really cool
and you know he was everybody was just
really down with finding a way to to
make sure that this was an actual
surprise and that in this moment you
never get surprises anymore
you never just get to wake up and you
know you're always sold something it's
always kind of shoved down your throat
for weeks and weeks and then finally you
see it and here was this opportunity to
just you know have something you had no
idea you're gonna watch and you got to
experience and start to finish we didn't
ruin any of it I'll never get to do that
with the movies and so it was a gift for
me and I love being able to do that
I believe that Mattel put out the toys
they did yeah they showed our hand right
exactly so when it started shipping were
you like this is how it's gonna get out
is the toys that's always how it is
we're I mean so you know the toys come
first and you know it Indiana I just
feel like that's just the way the
internet works now if you want to go out
and
want to get information about something
that information is there for you if you
decide you want to wait and be surprised
and have an experience you can make that
choice too
I think it's all it's all very
democratic now I'm very curious how you
and Amy hooked up to do the score this
time last year in October working on a
dream work short the universal team and
about a week later after we got back
rachelandmike no block from the
universal team called me and said Colin
Trevorrow just called with this shorts
and my stomach fell out yeah and then I
just sent a reel and then I actually
thought nothing of it and thought that's
never gonna happen in a million years
and then the week before Christmas my
agent called and said you're gonna be in
London over Christmas right now he's
like aren't you flying home I'm like to
Ireland it's not lonely he's like but
you're gonna be in London over Christmas
okay I guess I'm going to learn it so I
flew to London to meet with Colin for a
coffee meeting that turned into like a
three hour hang and yeah he told me all
about it and I was so pumped and then
and then they went to shoot in Ireland's
the following week and I took a couple
of weeks and demoed and wrote a score he
said pick a scene and and try it out and
of course I did the whole thing and yeah
and then a couple weeks later I got a
lovely email from Colin saying your demo
is effing awesome let's do this and then
yeah we worked on the score kind of on
and off for four or five months there
were a couple of different versions of
it that just just as things were
progressing I guess with the Edit and
everything we changed the score and then
we went out we rolled in May and
recorded a 80 piece Orchestra which we
were there for which was very fun and I
had a little cry on the podium with the
John Williams theme one thing that I
thought it was amazing about Amy's work
and is the way that she incorporates the
chiquinho and the Williams music into it
so effortlessly but if anything changed
over our time working on it it was
the encouragement to write your own
theme and to at which I know was like a
big fear for you call it initially had
said that my kind of thought know like
it's Jurassic Who am I who ever tried to
contribute anything new to this amazing
franchise that I'm so in love it and
grew up with and he kept pushing like
let's have a big rock team and I'm like
derived from the G Kino theme though
it's like no no no and just like super
force me to write the theme which you
hear three times in the short I
definitely want to know what it's like
stepping into for you Abbey Road you
were in the studio where the Beatles
recorded so much of their iconic music
if not all of it what is it like
recording in that room and for you being
there I mean it's just a magical place
oh yeah it's it's pure magic and the
musicians there are just insane like we
put pretty difficult charts down in
front of them and they sight read it we
were all just absolutely blown away it I
kept saying they're you know we'll get
this in five or six takes and we'll
piece it together and they just nailed
it first time and it was yeah I mean
everyone had goosebumps and it was yeah
it's a really magical place yeah did you
ask for like extra takes just to milk
being in Abbey Road we did for the brass
because I remember towards the end we
had kind of like an hour of extra time
because they've gone through it because
they were so good so we just kept doing
it just to enjoy it speaking of the end
credits I I mean I think everyone here
would agree the end credits in this
earth is awesome like just awesome I
want to know where that idea came from
let's start with that that was it
actually came after the fact we've done
it and we had a cut of it and it was
just in the editing room and it was this
sense that you know it was more of a
macro question of arguable why is this
like where does this fit into the story
that we're telling and it felts like you
know one of one of Amy's instincts was
you know we could have ended it
musically when you're pulling away from
the family with music that sounds like
it's reassuring and that they're safe
now and her instinct was no no let's
make it you know this is the this is
dreadful and terrible and oh my god the
foreboding image that we're showing you
suggests far more you know chaos and
destruction to
and so when I finally heard it with that
picture there was this sense of well
let's just show you know what this is
suggesting and it actually I think it
ultimately elevated the short to really
be about the status quo the state of the
world that we're heading into and how
that feels and what that really looks
like did you it's I believe it's real
footage that you sort of put stuff on
yeah I couldn't go back and shoot
anything so we just went on YouTube and
I made a list of all the things that I
wanted to see and we pull we got these
clips off YouTube and bought them from
who via that's just a little girl who
was running from ducks and her mom was
shooting it and so we bought it from the
family we replaced it with copies and
the car crashes like some guy really got
in a car crash and now if he goes online
you can see that there was a dinosaur
and the middle of it and each one of
them you know that that poor this couple
that you know was getting married I
think it's I think it was from a Russian
wedding and I what we don't know like
all of these people you know we're
compensated for it I don't know if
they've seen it or how they feel about
it that girl could be 20 now I know we
don't even know but something I'll
always have this which I think it's fun
is there I'm just gonna ask as a fan is
there any thought to doing any more of
those sort of bits that you did at the
end credits in any way or is it there is
yeah
well we'll find ways to integrate those
into the end of the proceedings as we
move forward I can tell you right I
understand um so I am curiously you see
you you have that you have the idea for
the short this is obviously a hugely
important franchise to Universal what
was it like sort of telling them what
you wanted to do and what was the
feedback from the studio you know what I
mean like how was that in that dynamic
the studio has always been very
supportive with us and and I think they
you know they recognize that ours is not
a franchise that that has this you know
how are you know I love Marvel films and
and yet they have this great advantage
of having these amazing stories that
have been told you know for 50 years and
you know these comic books these
mythological foundations that they're
able to build on we're just making this
stuff up as we go along which is a
tightrope walk and and I think the odds
of getting it right or wrong or are that
much greater and so the fact that the
studio has had so much faith in us too
follow our own instincts and figure out
you know which way we feel like this
story is naturally going like constantly
shocks me that they you know we're just
like a bunch of kids who really want to
see you know dinosaur movies and we get
to make them and then they just give us
the toys you're short is one of the rare
things that seems to be universally
praised online it's it's really hard to
do in this day and age so you obviously
we're I'm sure you were nervous as f
when this thing was getting ready to
premiere what has it been like for the
three of you watching this great
reception yeah I definitely was watching
with I was excited but terribly nervous
that I was just gonna be eviscerated
online because it's you know one of the
most iconic scores of all the time is
Jurassic Park and anyone who dares to
touch us better watch out so yeah I was
definitely prepped for some awful tweets
but they didn't it's been it's been so
fun to watch it all week and hear some
of you guys your thoughts and people
pulling the score apart I am so glad
that you guys said yes to watch it again
cuz we didn't get to see it the first
time and I so I have seen it on the big
screen but just seeing it here again
tonight with fans was amazing
I also I really like a I'm hearing on
the internet people are like watching it
like a lot and I think it's a great
movie to watch a lot because they do
think because it's so economical and
because it's so packed in there every
time you watch it like you see new stuff
every time I listen to it I hear new
stuff and the mix I hear like you know a
line that I didn't catch this like
interwoven and the montage at the top
and stuff like that so thank you thank
you for saying yes I second all of that
I you know I the I recognize these
moments are fleeting to see I saw my
wife came to me and she was like look on
Wikipedia says that it was received
positively by critics and fans alike and
I was like no say it again just say it
again I haven't heard that in a really
long time please
and there was it's Anna you know the
we put our hearts into this we put our
soul into it every time and sometimes
you know it's received one way and and
sometimes received another so to have
something go like this it meant a lot to
me so thank you very much if I'm not
mistaken you had some practical stuff on
set can you talk a little bit about the
balancing in this day and age of
practical and CGI and what the benefit
what you visual what you see is the
benefits of both well you know there's
actually Jay Bayona
innovated some things on fallen Kingdom
that we have been able to move forward
with and that he realized that we can
actually from a budgetary level and just
like a logistical practical level we can
up the number of of animatronic by
actual practical animals that we have if
we're not relying on all of the little
you know all of the hydraulics they're
really heavy inner workings of these the
ones that you know Steven used on the
first two movies and the Joe Johnson use
that are massive amazing beautiful
creatures are movies because we have you
know been animating them and they move
like they're a bit more lie than they
move quicker to be able to have a
lighter animal that doesn't have all the
machinery inside that can be more
puppeteered blue in the second movie was
a puppet with like eight you know eight
different puppeteers below it there
weren't a lot of actual moving gears
within her and it creates a different
kind of life this one it was the guys
from legacy who you know it's Stan
Winston's group and who continued to do
work for us they did the Apatosaurus in
the first movie and they made something
that you know the jar articulated and
you know it was photo real and the eyes
worked but it was light and it moves
really fast once it gets into the
basically everything once you get inside
of that box you know is the animatronic
it was just amazing first of all I was
able to light it a lot darker than I
probably would have a movie you know the
movies you know tend to be a little bit
brighter and more vibrant and we've made
a really moody dark thing which I was
excited to do and it was we were able to
you know mask the animatronic enough
that you know it feels you know really
scary and really real and there's just
something so you know the way that smoke
falls off of it it's so practical about
it right now for the next movie we're
working with John Nolan who did all of
the animatronics for the Dark Crystal
you guys have seen that and he's do like
the stuff that he's innovating is
extremely exciting you know it's small
and large and
doing with eyes look a lot of stuff we
learn from the dark crystal that he's
applying to Jurassic Park which is
thrilling you mentioned the next
Jurassic I heard rumors you're working
on that as well the I'm just going with
the thing I'm curious I'm sure people
are wondering are there things in the
short film that are little Easter eggs
to what's coming and how much is it sort
of like this is just a one shot you know
this is it's not really meant to tie in
same worlds same world same fabric you
will see strands strands that's all I'm
gonna say to me yeah it was kind of like
a tonal answer to a question I feel like
a lot of people saw where we ended the
last film and the feeling is oh it's
gonna be like a dinosaur human war and
they're gonna have guns they could go
any number of directions and so I think
for me it was important for us to answer
that question very clearly and to say
look this is how we see this these are
real animals in our world that we now
have to navigate and figure out how to
coexist with there and I think you know
just making sure the audience
understands from what angle were
approaching this creatively I think will
help us head into the next movie in the
same headspace I'm always curious about
the editing room because it's the final
rewrite talk a little bit about you get
in the editing room you have all the
footage what how did it change in the
editing room was it going to be
originally shorter was it going to be a
little longer and a music question what
is it like writing music for something
that's constantly sort of changing you
know what I mean and until you get the
locked picture what I originally had
demoed to was actually like sketch
boards just like sketches of a dinosaur
and and and they wouldn't change for
eight seconds so eventually when I
started getting edits every couple of
weeks it was about changing temples and
just reworking the music to hit very
specific shots on-screen which we
obviously didn't have but yeah I guess
as it as it went along it didn't change
too much I feel it was kind of a lot of
tightening up but there was no reworking
of scenes like things swapping around
in the structure or anything like that
so we had kind of the the crux of the
scored there and it was in case of yeah
just tightening it up over time and we
did we actually did we did pre biz for
this but we did it in VR and so we
actually shot live actors in a VR volume
we had taped off you know the set of
what the what the camper was going to be
and so we were really able to see it
even when the family's at dinner it was
real actors actually like grabbing
plates and playing off each other so you
felt the hand held you know naturalistic
vibe of the whole thing and Jurassic
Park is not a handheld franchise like
it's always you know the camera is very
heavy and used cranes and dollies and
it's very classical kind of filmmaking
so I think the you know this movie is
it's almost entirely handheld and it has
a kind of energy that we normally
haven't applied to these movies so a
little bit of it was an experiment for
me to see like if we you know if we
change the cinematic language of the
franchise is that something that's gonna
jar people or it's not gonna feel like
they're Jurassic Park anymore and it
didn't have that it made me really happy
to see that it didn't have the result of
people are open to shaking it up a
little bit
I'm already I believe getting the
wrap-up sign so do you can i how would
you like to play can I open it to the
audience can I continue what would you
do a couple question you want to do a
couple questions well it's a I want to
make sure I'm not gonna get killed by
the people over there I guess it's okay
we got a couple of minutes count um so I
guess we're right there in the front row
cancer and I don't know how you found
out bass in the crowd or you sent her
autographed posters to sell to help pay
for the astronomical
college kids so it was just struggling
and the only time I've ever as a
Jurassic fan an autograph hound and a
poster collector I was not disappointed
to lose the option that she was able to
make a lot of money so I'm gonna half of
my family we thank you oh that's so
great to hear that's so great to hear
huh yeah she made it she made it a white
shirt right there so a lot of people
especially after Battle of a rock really
love seeing and the extended world beats
outside of the hole and declare and
seeing sort of how dinosaur being
released into the world and impacting
everyone lives and showing just a little
outside bit and it's a lot of people are
wondering
more of that possibly in something like
you know a live-action three series er
you know sort of sort of an anthology
with independent stories and stuff like
that just to explore the world that is
now changed so do you want to sum up for
the four people that did four didn't
here are there gonna be any sort of
anthologies or any of more stories of
outside of the main characters in the
Jurassic well you know the third movie
does have other new characters in it and
we get to really see how the world is
being affected by all these changes you
know some day in the future I you know
I'm I'm sort of you know if the audience
demands it then then we will we will
provide but right now we have an
animated show camp Cretaceous this could
be on Netflix that's really really cool
you guys are gonna love it and the
animation is so like you get that that
dinosaur stuff you need like it's the
animation is that good it feels really
real so hopefully that will satiate us
all in between larger installments I saw
a hand I want to think right there yeah
yep that was a lot are you questions are
you shooting on film yeah we are
shooting on film 35 and 65 for sure okay
what was it what did you see the same
weird same two to one aspect ratio it's
kind of a thing and what was it been
picked up by a lot of people it was a
Vittorio Storaro was the first one to do
it and now like pretty much most thing
you know Game of Thrones a lot of stuff
on HBO Netflix are all using two to one
so I'm very proud and also pitching to
Spielberg did you [ __ ] what happened
yeah I mean it was you know you just
kind of I think everyone has had
experiences in their lives where you
realize like alright well like if I can
if I can I have to be the most myself I
can possibly be for this perk because I
know this person is looking into my soul
they're not listening to whatever
[ __ ] I'm saying they're like they're
judging me in the deepest possible ways
as a human right
now and that's how I felt walking in
there and even you know four or five
years later I don't look at it any other
way that's that's what was going on he
was looking into my soul I want to look
right over there
sure one will we ever find out what
happens up north from yeah I know those
kind of things where you don't ever find
out what happened up north but I just
like suggesting a larger world you know
that you you just realized something
else that's going on out there okay and
then my second question is if this is
kind of for Emily and Colin do will we
see any older characters in the third
film will we see any characters in the
third Jurassic world meaning I mean from
one or two or even three well I would be
honored to work with any of those actors
again I'm you know especially especially
honored to work with were I given the
chance you know these three because I am
just as much of a fan as all of you what
is exciting for me is that I get to
bring new actors into the franchise and
I've gotten we've gotten to work with
you know with BD Wong and Jeff Goldblum
in this movie I get to have absolutely
one of my favorite actors in the world
is going to be in this movie she also
happens to have been in Jurassic Park
and she's here right now Laura Dern can
you come out here she here
there she is
[Applause]
[Music]
so I haven't seen or you can stand just
be in the light so Loras is returning in
Jurassic world 3 in a major role and not
a cameo in the whole movie would you
like to share anything else with this
fruit I'm so excited I'm so excited to
have you share this news and be here
with all of you hi I love dinosaurs I
love that you love them like we do and
if it's not asking too much if I'm gonna
get to join this party again I just I
would hate to not bring my friends Sam
Neill and Jeff open with them is that
okay with you yeah let's do it
all right let's do it guys you heard it
here first so you were the first to hear
this that sam neill and Jeff Goldblum
and Laura Dern are returning in major
roles in dress brought through thank you
guys for coming tonight
you are the hardcore fans I love you
very much thank you and we'll see you in
a year and a half see you see you soon
guys
[Applause]